- Argh!
I hate this! I hate this so much.
This is the worst thing
I've ever done for BuzzFeed.
Easily.
All I know about threading
is it looks like floss.
- I know that there's some string.
- String. Needles?
I don't know. What goes on?
Needles?
No? Oh, thank God.
There's no needles.
- I know nothing about threading.
- Hopefully I won't even notice it.
Is that stupid?
(increasing orchestral music)
- Hi, my name is Aruna.
- Hi, I'm Daisha.
- Less Greek.
- [Aruna] You want more manly, right?
- Hmm, meh.
- Well, I want the to look even.
- They will grow back?
- I go, get it down more.
- Is there a seatbelt?
- Oh yeah. That is nice.
Oh, that feels sooo nice.
- Oh wow.
- Okay, and that is just like
normal, like, sewing thread?
- [Aruna] Yes, it's normal.
Ready?
- No.
- We gonna take your hair,
we gonna remove your hair with the thread.
- Ah! Oh my God!
Um... (laughs)
- Oh my God!
- I will say that there are...
many other things I'd
rather be doing than this.
Like...
I don't know, being
punched in the stomach.
- The middle, like the
area she's doing now,
is actually not painful at all.
- Argh, wow.
- [Aruna] Are you OK?
- Ah, I suppose. Argh!
- Are you wiping blood off?
- [Aruna] A little bit.
A little bit? Okay, that's fine.
- I didn't even volunteer for this video.
Gabby volunteered me for this video.
- Note to self, don't
wear make-up next time.
- Um... (laughs)
- Ow!
I'm sure it's fine, Aruna.
- Yeah, it's okay, don't worry.
Yeah, we done.
- Woo!
- Um, yeah.
I look a little less Greek.
- Ooh, that's clean.
Oh shit.
- It felt like all my
eyebrows would be gone.
- That was quick and easy.
- The girls, they're used
to waxing and everything,
they're so much tougher than me.
- Yeah, I would bring a police officer or
a fireman next time.
If I were to do this again.
- God, I'm such a baby.
- I don't think I could ever get
this precise with tweezers.
Like, yes. Yes.
- I did it.
I'm happy that I have
unfleek eyebrows, yes.
Was it worth the journey?
I'm not sure. We'll see.